President Trump in recent days has been
taking a much tougher and far more
aggressive stance against the corner
virus and he told reporters he's always
taken the virus seriously this is a
pandemic I felt it was a pandemic long
before it was called a pandemic but a
review of the president's comments in
january/february and earlier this month
suggest otherwise the words about a
pandemic at this point oh we're not at
all and where we have it totally under
control it's one person coming in from
China and we have it under control it's
gonna be just fine now the Democrats are
politicizing the coronavirus you know
that this is that new hoax
but the president is no longer
soft-pedaling the magnitude of this
crisis saying the virus could last until
July or August we have a problem that a
month ago nobody ever thought about this
is a bad one this is a very bad one this
is bad in the sense that it's so
contagious and many in the media
welcoming the president's new and
sharper tone he is being the kind of
leader that people need at least in tone
today and yesterday the president's tone
has changed this is not something that
should be applauded necessarily or
frankly something that should be
expected to continue this is where he
should have been all along the president
was sober he actually he did what a
president's supposed to do he delivered
the bad news joining us now here in
Washington is Stephanie Grisham the
White House press secretary welcome I
may have to interrupt our conversation
to get to Cal Governor Cuomo for at
least a couple of minutes as I said many
people in the media are welcoming even
praising the president's new and more
aggressive tone even as some journalists
say he should have been speaking and
acting this way much earlier what caused
the shift you know I don't know that
there was a shift per se you've got to
remember the president he declared a
national health emergency in January he
took his decisive action to shut down
the borders with China very very early
and he's taken many bold actions since
then including shutting down borders
with Europe so he has acted
appropriately as we have learned and had
new developments about this virus but
you know many programs have played clip
similar to what I just did many have
written stories in which the president
said things like we've totally got it
under control so it does seem you know
you don't take my word for it it seems
too many people Stephanie that earlier
he was not where he is today in terms of
full-scale mobilization well the virus
we the virus wasn't where it was today
at the at the beginning either and I
would also say I don't know why the
media has to continue to look backwards
you've got a look at what the president
reported right there